all right today's topic juicy uh juicy's
going to jail
for three months or is it six months
four
and like what three years of probation
yeah
this is just me or [ __ ] like that's too
light do you feel like there should be
heavier sentences i don't really know
actually
i think i think with stuff like this
with hoaxes like this i don't think it
should just be a fine or slap on the
wrist i think if you uh put this kind of
stuff out there and put other people at
risk you should go to jail for serious
time
we need to dissuade people from even
thinking about doing stuff like this
because if you look at it the pros and
cons for him was pretty heavy on the
pros for the most part
it would have made him more famous more
money the cons
if it's already a stagnating career that
wasn't going to go anywhere the khans
are only he's shamed publicly but he's
only shamed publicly not because of the
court case but because the publicity
yeah right so the cons would only have
been three to four months in jail and
probation that's nothing that's nothing
it's same thing for women who accuse
dudes of doing something yeah right
women will say like oh he took and it
didn't happen it didn't happen well they
go to jail for what a few months the
dude was facing like 20 years some of
them actually go to jail for like half
that time before they get out most of
the time they don't get in jail so
that's what i'm saying like i don't know
i
to me seeing him go to jail well i think
it's the right thing i think 100 he
should be sent there because it's very
clear he was faking it but
the amount of time is just like meh if i
did this then it means that i stuck my
fist in the fears of black americans in
this country for over 400 years and the
fears of the lgbtq community your honor
i respect you and i respect the jury but
i did not do this and i am not
and if anything happens to me when i go
in there
i did not do it to myself and you must
all know
they know like the reason why right now
he's being held in a psychiatric
ward and the reason for that is that
when you say some [ __ ] like that if
something happens to me you know i
didn't do it but you already lied you
already lied about what you did to what
was done to you
so when you say something like that
they think you might
ask nigerian brothers to do something to
you inside of jail the first time he
lied about being harmed and now he's
claiming he will not harm himself what
would you believe i mean that and that's
the reason why they're putting you in a
psychiatric crowd what
right right there and then just the fact
that all this was
proven to be fake
and you say that you didn't do it
no the people that you paid did it i
mean it is susta
it is such that he says i didn't do it i
didn't do it and if i go inside and
something happens to me i didn't do it
to myself what are you trying to say you
should say yes seriously all of this are
you are you trying to make us believe
that there's some kind of specific
conspiracy to fake that you fake the
hate crime and that you didn't like what
are you talking about
that's the reason why you're in the
psychiatric ward ruff you're not on the
set of empire anymore
stop acting okay i won
no you're not getting no bonus pay
you're not getting no overtime pay no
all right you're not getting no after
nafta after awards nobody gonna
celebrate this acting career you have no
yeah that's the reason why you're there
yeah it sounded like he was acting at
the end when he's doing that speech
you're on i respect but i if you think i
put my fist in the 400 years of black
american suffering at the lgbt [ __ ]
please that's not stop stop that this
ain't it you're doing too much you're
doing too much you're doing a lot
you know what also killed me taraji
piano being like the family yes
read the statements
from taraji p and the family yeah i saw
what taraji said read it
so if you know taraji p was one of the
actors that once said to him and this is
what she wrote she wrote free juicy
hashtag okay i'm not here to debate
i'm here to debate you on innocence but
we can agree that the punishment does
not fit the crime we agree he should be
going to jail for much longer
if that's what you meant
but that's not what she meant you know
what she's saying he doesn't deserve to
go to jail at all emmett till was
brutally being no
don't put em into it in there don't put
em until in there don't do not go ahead
do not that's a fake equivalency that's
not what it is all right uh emmental was
brutally beat and
ultimately murdered because of a lie and
none of the people involved with his
demise spent one day in jail it's not
because over there
with emmett till there was no justice
that
jessie shouldn't pay for exactly
no
just she said jesse should pay and the
[ __ ] that did that that did
dirty to emmett till they should have
paid too that's it
but don't put don't emmett till in there
one day in jail
even after carolyn bryant admitted
that her claims were false no one was
hurt or killed during jesse's ordeal
nah you still deserve it keep reading it
keep reading it don't stop
don't stop didn't get enough got enough
he has already lost everything
everything to me as an artist not able
to create that itself is punishment
enough
he can't get no job no one in hollywood
will hire him
and again as an artist who loves to
create that is prison my prayer is that
he is freed and put on house risk and
probation because in this case that
would seem fair please free jesse no
you think you said something taraji p
you didn't she basically said what juicy
did is lowkey noble she was basically
endorsing what he did nobody was hurt
what's the issue oh he's suffering he
can't create art anymore imagine if we
got off most people in prison offline or
they can't do what they love anymore
listen
it's not because nobody was hurt or
killed that it makes it okay yeah the
same way if you go and attempt to slice
somebody's neck and you fail it's not
because nobody was hurt or killed and
you failed that you didn't do something
terrible
you know he knew what kind of profile he
has he knew what this was going to do
for his career and he got the whole
world to listen in on this whole thing
and claim that he was a victim of a hate
crime at a time where like racial
tensions are really high you faking
something makes people look at you
sideways it does something terrible for
race relations in general yeah and you
just you just said the whole race
relation thing back everybody that had a
case there
the real victims
are gonna be looked funny like you you
did a disservice to a bunch of people
you put a bunch of people on on the case
and on edge i be you get what you
deserve and you should deserve more yeah
this is the type of person to say like
well women who falsely accuse dude who
don't go to jail shouldn't be what
you you put someone straight life under
stress
basically libel not a thing for her you
know what i'm saying defamation of
character is not a thing for her no no
stop nobody was really hurt yeah but the
next time somebody comes out with a hate
crime and they say something happened to
me you know what they're gonna say are
you another juicy yeah
that's what they're gonna say yeah
definitely and and rightly so because we
have learned through this case and
through many others that being a victim
in a lot of these circumstances carries
a tremendous amount of power and benefit
he did this for career opportunities to
advance himself
think about that i respect you your
honor i respect your decision
jail time
i am not suicidal okay
mr ucha let me inquire are there any
post-sentencing motions you care to
present right now yes judge yes ms the
defense would wish to present a motion
to reconsider sentence
all right and file it and stand here
it is it is timely filed thank you judge
and and let me say i've obviously
considered the sentence at great length
and and it's timely filed so it's
preserved for purposes of appeal motion
to reconsider sentences respect all
right we stopped watching we stopped
watching we can stop watching
and yeah i think the biggest take away
from this is a lot of people will make
up anything to frame themselves as a
victim because they know it's beneficial
that's the truth of the world so
whenever someone says to you why would
anyone make something like this up
you're learning now
that behind the scenes it's a tremendous
currency
this man's talking about promotions
bigger roles he wanted his whole profile
to raise up because he was ambitious and
how did he want to do it by being a
victim
so there you have it
there you have it people lie every day
like this
and this is a real thing doesn't mean
you shouldn't believe anybody who comes
out with this look at the facts in the
case of evidence whatever it might be
but if you ever think to yourself but no
nobody would make something up
you're wrong
i've seen it with my own eyes and
everyone's seen it with this case in
this question
this man didn't care about putting those
two nigerian brothers
in a super compromising position what if
the police rolled up on them really
believing was a hate crime and then some
kind of thing happened we see that all
the time in videos somebody reaches for
their hand too quickly their cell phone
whatever it might be boom boom boom what
then
what then of course this man's guilty
and his whole family talking about
freedom he didn't do nothing wrong
listen
their family so they got to say that
i guess free my [ __ ] tico what what
what the tico did oh you killed five
people
oh no tico can say yeah it's like come
on man chico can tell that's a jail oh
no we're not freaking nobody yeah he did
that
then he's gonna do that
now the whole city of chicago is like
man get this get this full out of here
keep him in jail but that's just my
thoughts
everything was sucks from the beginning
hey man we don't have to hash that [ __ ]
out everybody knows the story let me
know what you guys think in the comments
below do you guys believe this do not
believe me